allô mamie nicole est au chevet de sa
mère en CHSLD depuis deux mois Marcel
Iran 95 ans a perdu son autonomie à une
vitesse fulgurante est-ce que tu veux
dire quelque chose
sa vie bascule le 16 janvier dernier
quand elle marche pour aller sous souper
dans sa RPA la préposé au bénéficiaire
devant sa marché est impuissante au
moment de la chute la personne qui a
fait l'erreur n'a pas pu retenir ma mère
donc ma mère est tombée au sol et ses
fracturé le fémur il se fait opérer le
lendemain de l'accident puis son état de
santé se détériore rapidement ma mère
est en train de sombrer
ma mère Nicolas a regardé en boucle la
vidéo de surveillance que lui a
transmise la résidence pour aimer l'îlot
à l'Île Perrot je me dis que ça aurait
pu être évité s'il y avait eu une bonne
technique si est-ce que les gens ont des
formations correctes pour justement
faire leur travail la personne qui
accompagne les bénéficiaires ou le
patient devrait se mettre à côté et
placer une main en fait doucement dans
le bas du dos la technique sécuritaire
est pourtant bien connue à bout de bras
Marcel ne parvient pas à suivre la
cadence trop rapide quelle était déjà un
déséquilibre quand elle a commencé à
marcher il le fait que la préposé vers
l'avant
la marchette en partiel mais ça fait en
sorte que ça ça n'occupe plus la
déstabiliser davantage dans une
déclaration l'entreprise propriétaire de
la résidence indique avoir rapidement
congédie l'employé qui en dépit de toute
notre bonne volonté et de notre
formation rigoureuse n'a pas respecté
l'esprit et la lettre des normes de
qualité en vigueur au Groupe Maurice les
chutes nombreuses n'ont rien d'anodin le
réseau public de la santé québécois a
recensé plus de 180 000 chutes ou quasi
chute dans un contexte de prestation de
soins au cours de l'année 2020 2021
374 d'entre elles ont contribué au décès
de l'usager même dans l'espace que vous
avez puis que vous évoquez